et on prend la direction de l'est de
l'ukraine bonjour chez bien sida on vous
retrouve sur la route deux arts au pizza
c'est en ukraine que se passe-t-il sur
place et y at il des mouvements de
troupes les russes sont ils entrés dans
cette ville que constatez-vous
oui bonjour julien nous sommes
effectivement entre marie paule et
zaporizhya sur la vie de
bombardements ont été entendus dans le
port il ya un peu plus d'une heure
maintenant ainsi que des échanges de
tirs entre l'armée ukrainienne et les
groupes russes d'après une source
militaire
six militaires indique titre des navires
russes militaires russes se trouvaient
aux abords du port pour enfants et les
tâches gré sur le porte
que les ukrainiens de leur côté ils
étaient prêts à risquer cas d'attaqué un
peu plus tôt dans la journée des
bombardements avaient été entendues dans
la banlieue de la ville à l'est de
marie-paule très exactement
les défenses des déflagrations ont eu
lieu vers 5h30 ce matin dont une très
forte peu après et maintenant que tu es
frappes ont visé des bases militaires
ukrainienne dans une position de défense
aérienne
voilà un petit souci technique je ne
sais pas si on va pouvoir continuer
julien alors on réessaie donnez nous le
sentiment de la population donc
qui suit bien sûr l'évolution de la
situation et de cette guerre qui a
commencé ce matin
alors du côté de la population julien il
ya évidemment beaucoup de peurs
marioupol est une très grande ville 450
mille personnes y vivent et ceux qui ont
choisi de fuir se sont rués sur les
banques mais le retrait sont désormais
limitée à 2000 hryvnias ukrainien soit
60 euros il ya aussi eu des queues à la
pharmacie et surtout on l'a constaté à
de très longues files d'attentes se sont
formées aux stations essence doigté
plusieurs jours que des rumeurs
couraient sur une éventuelle invasion
russe dans la ville mais hier encore les
deux titans nous disait une pas y croire
et aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de mouvement
de panique mais les deux habitants se
sont réveillés totalement hagard sous le
bruit des bombes ils ont tenté de faire
leurs bagages comme comme ils le
pouvaient de prendre remettre du minimum
nécessaire mais il ne semblait pas prêt
à tout quitter précipitamment pourquoi
est-ce que marioupol serait une cible
stratégique pour vladimir poutine julien
et bien déjà parce que mario folle
allure un très grand port marchand donc
tous - économique de la région pour moi
économique aussi pour qu'elle puisse que
mario paul et jusqu'à présent la
dernière grande ville sous contrôle
ukrainiens donc moins économique mais
aussi marioupol et ray est intéressant
point de vue stratégique puisqu'elle se
situe entre le dombass à l'est est la
crim est annexée par les russes au sud
lorsque vladimir poutine a reconnu
l'indépendance des deux régions
séparatistes de londres qui est honnête
qu'il avait précisé par la suite qu'il
reconnaissait les oblasts donc pas dire
la région de los andes et de dawn est et
la région de donetsk comprend notamment
la ville et les alentours de marioupol
et au delà de réunir la crimée aux dons
bas cela permettrait tout simplement à
la russie de contrôler toute la mer
d'azov
merci beaucoup julien chedid a donc sur
la route entre marioupol les apories jah
pour france24 merci pour ces éléments